explain the situation in Guerrero right
now on September 26 municipal police in
the city of Iguala in guro state Mexico
attacked several bus loads of students
from the rural Teachers College and
iosing Appa killing a total of six
people wounding more than 20 and
disappearing 43 students one of the
students bodies was found at 10:00 in
the morning with his face eyes and ears
removed since then the students and the
family members of those disappeared have
been demanding that the state act to
find their sons and their colleagues
alive to return them to them alive and
now the federal police is being sent in
do you think that that's gonna change
anything in terms of the search sadly
the the federal police debris on the
ground for weeks and nothing really has
changed the disturbing thing here is
this again is one of these cases I think
of a massacre foretold for years there
have been stories of mass disappearances
of Central American migrants in the
northern water regions all of these mass
graves and mass disappearances were
thought to simply be criminal
organizations fighting each other and
hence the indignation the social
mobilization is necessary to pressure
the government to investigate
I think the Mexican state strategy will
be to strip any political content from
the violence by saying it was a drug
cartel and this kids provoked them right
they'll try and not make the kids look
too bad because that would have I think
devastating consequences on the ground
in Mexico where people are justly livid
and outraged at this there were mass
graves found in the hunt for these
students and it turns out that the
students actually weren't the ones
buried in those graves what does that
say in terms of the state of violence in
the region and the fact that
investigators are sort of just tripping
over these horrible sights of of death
there are two questions now right who
are those people what happened to them
who did that to them and then also of
course we
the 43 students so why target students I
think the alt Napa Teachers College is
one of the most underfunded institutions
that the country that its students are
from some of the poorest most
economically marginalized or brutalized
municipalities in the country many from
indigenous communities and from rural
farm working communities but are they
seen as a threat to absolutely Mexican
state absolutely explain that the
Mexican state has a discourse of hate
and criminalization of the students
that's very very long-standing and it's
been called a nursery for guerrilla
fighters for decades so this car that's
been targeted for decades it seems like
everyone who is outside of Mexican
politics or a former politician or an
analyst everyone but the actual current
Mexican government agrees that the drug
war is a failure all these studies come
out these opinions right so if it's a
failure how is it and will it end the
drug war itself has been entirely
successful at maintaining the drug war
it's not been successful of anything
else it constantly expands and maintains
and fuels the waring itself and the war
is very good business one more
download the aj+ mobile app and join the
conversation available in your App Store
now